il fêté ses 20 ans en septembre 2004
avant d'être ferme et trois ans plus
tard
promesse de campagne de michel logis en
le collège bergson a été détruit en 2017
pour de nouveau accueillir la jeunesse
ini monteyne au sein d'un forum des arts
ce bâtiment va permettre de regrouper
toutes toutes sortes d'activités qui
étaient aujourd'hui explosé dans des
finales dans des salles communales ou
même dans le petit conservatoire de
musique
si aujourd'hui était vraiment trop petit
pour le nombre d'élèves accueillir les
premières lettres du forum des arts
charles aznavour apparaissent 3400
mètres carrés qui accueilleront théâtre
musique et danse
les travaux ont débuté en juin dernier
pour une livraison prévue en avril 2021
aujourd'hui ce qui est fait donc c'est
toute la partie sous sol avaient donc
l'auditorium de 150 places qu'en diront
sur 350 mètres carrés
la mula salle de percussions et le
parking de 20 places avec des places de
pour les vélos et non sur ces places il
y aura des places pour des véhicules et
des véhicules électriques tout le rez de
chaussée et termine également donc on
ressort on revoit l'auditorium qui
assure deux niveaux qui ressort ici
quatre salles de théâtre et la partie
administrative
un projet confié au maître d'oeuvre
strasbourgeois à dominique coulon est
associé spécialiste des bâtiments
culturels aux normes acoustiques
particulière
coût total 18 millions d'euros dont la
majorité est financé par des subventions
et les recettes des logements construits
sur le terrain on voit bien la voix qui
va desservir le bâtiment public et les
quatre îlots de le les quatre îlots de
logements bien séparés quatre îlots
comprenant environ 140 logements dont
des logements sociaux pour ce faire
quatre autres grues jammes rond au
printemps